a principios de 2022 el gobierno de río
de janeiro lanzó la polémica operación
ciudad integrada para controlar el
crimen en las favelas jacarezinho la
favela donde en mayo de 2021 se llevó a
cabo una incursión que mató a 28 jóvenes
fue invadida recientemente por la
policía en el marco de este programa
[Música]
pocos días después la orden de abogados
se registró en los primeros casos de
violaciones de los derechos humanos
buenas tardes este activista del
jacarezinho denuncia que seis policías
invadieron su domicilio le desnudaron y
le torturaron durante horas
me dieron muchos puñetazos en las
costillas afectadas en la cabeza
objetadas con la mano abierta también en
la cara también realmente pensé que me
mataría me pusieron un pañuelo en la
boca y otro policía colocó un cuchillo
en mi muñeca
modificó todo como fuck a los grupos y
ellos comencé a llorar a chepo for
london tfl o felipe relata que también
le confiscaron el teléfono y todos sus
documentos sólo consiguió recuperar su
documentación de trabajo este abogado
asegura que el caso de felipe no es
aislado
tenemos aquí varios relatos de casas las
habilidades y mandatos judiciales y
muchos relatos de que en estas
operaciones durante las situaciones de
las policías la tortura es algo
realmente es la tortura
[Música]
en el palacio guanabará el centro del
poder en río de janeiro el gobernador
hace el primer balance de la operación
ciudad integrada
desde hace mucho tiempo nuestra policía
es acusada de ser una fuerza que entrar
para pegar tiros
lo que es una gran injusticia
nuestra policía está entrando a las
favelas para liberar a las personas del
yugo del narcotráfico y de las milicias
[Música]
este político que aspira a ganar las
próximas elecciones de octubre para
mantenerse en el cargo aprovecha el acto
para promocionarse ante la élite de río
de janeiro
la ciudad integrada es una gran
propuesta
y es un programa que se propone cambiar
la idea con la que miramos a las favelas
[Música]
aquí
a 13 km del lujoso palacio de gobierno
la realidad es muy diferente el río que
atraviesa la favela de jacarezinho está
lleno de desechos aunque el gobierno
además de seguridad ofrece realizar
obras públicas en las favelas escogidas
es imposible vivir aquí cuando el río se
llena los vecinos de aquí quieren todo
nosotros estamos acostumbrados a
movernos dentro de este río desde
pequeños pero ahora dejar que un niño
pise allí es peligroso causa
enfermedades a ciencia cierta el
gobierno local nunca cumplió su promesa
de recuperar esa área los políticos sólo
aparecen en época de elecciones fuera de
esta época
se olvidan de nosotros
para esta pastora evangélica el programa
ciudad integrada debería crear empleo
dentro de jacarezinho no necesitamos que
nadie venga de fuera para hacer estas
obras aquí hay mano de obra queremos una
oportunidad para trabajar porque estamos
capacitados por lo pronto los vecinos se
quejan de que la llegada de la policía
ha paralizado la actividad económica
dentro de la favela perjudicando a los
ambulantes
roberto vende carne a la parrilla desde
que la policía invadió esta favela las
ventas cayeron implicada en realidad
nuestro trabajo empeoró si saliera para
hacer lo que hacía hace tres meses no
consigo vender mi mercadería como hacía
antes no sólo yo todos los vendedores
están iguales la quiebra económica se
suma al luto de esta familia el año
pasado su hijo fue ejecutado por la
policía con dos tiros en la espalda fue
la operación más sangrienta de la
historia del río
en la forma que tengo de decir
que esté de una madre hoy
tiene
que tenía un nombre y un apellido que
tenía una familia
que no era un perro porque así es como
lo trataron lo arrastraron un muerto por
el callejón
mateos tenía 21 años y dos hijas la
policía le acusa de pertenecer al
narcotráfico pero su madre lo niega
aunque mi hijo tuviese 300 denuncias
aunque hubiese sido encarcelado yo
lucharía contra esa injusticia porque en
brasil no existe la pena de muerte si él
hubiese hecho algo errado en aquel
momento tendría que haberle arrestado no
ejecutarlo y encima han archivado el
caso de mi hijo
la masacre de jacarezinho causó
conmoción dentro y fuera de brasil las
naciones unidas- y llegaron a exigir una
investigación independiente
nueve meses después el grito de dolor de
esas madres que perdieron a sus hijos en
una guerra no declarada se pierde entre
el ruido de una ciudad que ya se
acostumbró a una rutina de violencia
más tarde
y me escucha el alarido del yacaré ciñó
contra la enésima muerte de un joven
negro a manos de la policía
[Aplausos]